we learn nothing if we don't understand
wins and losses when they happen Bernie
Sanders has lost this primary and I know
that there are still people in my
audience who want me to continue drawing
up scenarios where Bernie could win I
don't think that that's productive I
think it's more productive and
informative to understand why Bernie
Sanders lost this primary so might
here's it just a suggestion to the the
Bernie or bust people who I know are in
Mirat my audience because their tweet
tweeting me like crazy tweeting me a lot
of anti-semitic stuff too by the way
which is disturbing to see from people
supposedly on the left instead of just
being mad at me
listen to the content of what I'm going
to outline and tell me where you think I
may be wrong or where you think I may be
right so let's discuss why Bernie lost
later I'll talk about you know the
people emailing me emailing me saying I
will never vote for Joe Biden I'm out
I'm not voting or I'll write someone in
or all vote third party or Trump even in
some cases let's deal with these things
one at a time I get that this is going
to be painful for a lot of people in my
audience but if we don't do this we
learn nothing
why did Bernie lose you're not going to
get any hot takes from me here about the
DNC rigged it and took it from Bernie
the establishment robbed Bernie the
reasons people lost are that primarily
not enough people wanted him to win and
they didn't vote for him okay there is
no question that if you say well the
establishment stole it
there's no doubt that moderates in this
race we're talking about Amy and Pete
and eventually Michael Bloomberg they
decided at some point I'm gonna get out
of the way because I want my support to
go to Biden that's the path forward
they are moderates they want a moderate
they did what they needed to do to get a
moderate in a position to win you can't
deny that there's no doubt about that
but it's not stealing it from Bernie
it's realizing hey there's millions of
moderates voting in the Democratic
primary it's an electorate that doesn't
want Bernie to win and they consolidated
their support around one candidate and
that can that it was Biden I would like
the democratical
to be more progressive it's not right
now it's just not and that's part of why
Bernie Sanders lost understand and the I
know that this is so painful
Bernie only has 30% of the primary vote
so far 30% even yesterday when it was
Biden versus Bernie alone there are
states where Bernie barely got 15% he
didn't get as of right now even 15% in
Mississippi in some of the other states
Missouri Michigan Bernie had 34 36% in a
two-person race Bernie never pulled more
than 35% until everyone left the race
and for the most part was polling 23 22
% for most of this race we're looking at
Bernie's polling now his highest polling
level nationally in the Democratic
primary was 23 back in April until
candidates started leaving and even with
a two-person race against Biden Bernie
is still only polling 35 percent right
now so the corporate media was very
wrong early on the corporate media said
Bernie can't get to 20 his ceilings like
15 17 they were very wrong then the
corporate media said Bernie's ceiling is
25 with the Democratic electorate they
were wrong but there clearly is a
ceiling because Bernie even in a
two-person race he's getting as little
as 15% in some states and just never
polled more than 23 until the race
emptied out and it was him versus Biden
we've got to wake up guys this sucks I
get it the Democratic Party isn't that
progressive Joe Biden is not going to
put in the progressive policies that I
would like to see put in put put in
there but the DNC establishment doesn't
need to steal it from someone who never
pulls more than 23 during 90% of the
race and is losing some states with 15%
of the vote and right now is losing the
popular vote in the primaries by 1.5
million that's before Florida even votes
it's conceivable that Bernie will lose
this primary in the popular vote by more
than two million votes this is a primary
folks so listen it hurts but we learn
and gain nothing by just insisting they
took
they stole it from Bernie No the
moderates got together and because
there's so many of them in the party
they won now this gets us to the next
part of the analysis and I want people
to listen very closely here
why didn't more people vote for Bernie
Sanders why didn't Bernie get to more
than 23% support in the polls nationally
until it was just him versus Biden or at
least fewer people one piece certainly
is that Bernie's biggest support
age-wise comes from 18 to 29 year olds
on a percentage basis 18 to 29 year olds
aren't reliable voters but that's too
simplistic that's true but it's too
simplistic
Bernie loss because of essentially three
different issues number one
Bernie's policies aren't as popular as
some of us on the progressive left like
to believe it's it sucks I mean it hurts
to realize that that's number one number
two the branding of Bernie's campaign
was not good in the sense that while it
was a great branding for the progressive
left for the bulk of the Democratic
primary voters it was not good branding
and number three and you all know I've
been covering this for years
Bernie has some very toxic people around
him that a lot of voters are instantly
repelled by so let's go through these
one by one let's start with policy okay
let's take Medicare we often say
Medicare for all is super popular in the
United States everybody wants it so it's
obviously great for Bernie to outline it
the way that he outlines it so it is
true people overwhelmingly want Medicare
for all as an option when it is worded
in a particular way but when you say to
people are you in favor of your private
insurance no longer being an option and
you having to have Medicare for all
support goes way down now I'm giving you
two opposing ways to present it and then
we're gonna get into the details this is
all based on polling from the Kaiser
Family Foundation they're very very good
on this if you say to people do you want
a universal government plan available
regardless of ability to pay support is
off-the-charts 70 75 80 percent very
high support if you say should the
government regulate the health insurance
industry the health care industry
support is very
very high if you say to people what if
private insurance were abolished to make
way for this support is 37% okay you
aren't going to win a primary when your
main policy that you were known for has
only 37 percent support under some
versions of it it hurts I wish this
wasn't the case but it is when you say
emergency care will be available to all
and quickly under a medical care for all
program but like in other countries wait
times for non-emergency procedures may
increase unless you want to go to a
private clinic and pay out-of-pocket
popularity goes way down so one part of
this is that we on the Left often assume
people vote Biden over Bernie because
they don't understand Bernie's plans for
example and if they did they would
obviously vote for Bernie Sanders the
facts don't bear that out
it pains me to say it the Democratic
Party is way more conservative than we
progressives like to think that's
problem number one taking health care as
an example we could apply it to others
number two second problem with Bernie's
campaign I've said this for years this
is not Monday morning quarterbacking go
look at my videos the framing of
Bernie's campaign has been a problem
why is Bernie calling himself a
Democratic Socialist his campaign is a
campaign of social democracy why call
yourself something you aren't and then
when people bring it up he says well I'm
talking about democratic socialism like
Denmark not Venezuela you're creating an
optional problem there is no reason to
do this and the rebuttals have been very
lame one rebuttal when I say this is
David the rights gonna call him a
socialist either way so he might as well
call himself that why should he call
himself that if it doesn't apply just
because Republicans will call him that
that's not a good argument and by the
way this is something that hurt him in
the Democratic primary the fact that
Republicans are gonna call him a
socialist either way is different than
the problem that he has in the
Democratic primary North Florida
Democrats aren't that thrilled about
voting for someone who calls themself a
Democratic Socialist Missouri Democrats
aren't that thrilled about voting for a
Democratic Socialist so it heard him the
talk of revolution also heard him it
doesn't bother me it doesn't bother me
but the Democratic electorate didn't
want it and that's why Bernie has thirty
percent of the primary votes so far
lastly Bernie had and has toxic people
around him that a lot of Democratic
voters simply want nothing to do with I
told you yesterday that Sunday night
Bernie was introduced at a Michigan
rally by this Imam who suggested the
conspiracy that Isis is really
controlled by Israel playing this
anti-semitic trope of you know there are
Jews crafty Jews behind the scenes in
the shadows actually the puppet masters
of everything that you see it's an
anti-semitic trope the guy introduced
Bernie Sunday night there's a longer
list of people we don't need to go
through it now so this is the reality I
can't pretend like it's anything else
because I would be dishonest now people
will be mad at me some of you will
unsubscribe because I'm talking to you
like adults about things as they are
rather than things as I would wish them
to be you should see what was going on
on Twitter last night I was getting
destroyed but I don't care okay the
stakes are too high and so I'm not gonna
play games here and I'm just going to
tell it like it is I'm told that there
are channels that will just keep telling
you here's how Bernie can still win
here's how Bernie can still win if
that's what you want if that will
placate you for another few weeks or a
month or whatever that's available
that's not gonna be this channel if you
want channels to tell you why you should
feel good about not voting for Biden
even if it helps Donald Trump get
reelected you can find those and that's
the thing I'm going to talk about on the
other side of the interview what about
this issue of to vote for Biden or not
the Bernie or bust component blank votes
no votes all of this stuff we're gonna
deal with that later in the meantime
though for more on this make sure you're
following us on instagram at david
pakman show follow me at David Pakman
while you are there as well check out
the excellent YouTube channel we're
partnering up with called up flip you
can get there at david pakman.com slash
up flip the link is right underneath
this video
make sure you subscribe while you are
there up flip is a YouTube channel that
looks at entrepreneurship in a very
interesting way their content looks at
small businesses what makes them
successful each video you get to meet a
new entrepreneur get a behind-the-scenes
look at their daily grind learn their
philosophy learn their business as a
business owner myself as someone with an
MBA I love watching the content there's
a ton of really useful insight to come
away with from every episode I love
hearing what the entrepreneurs share you
get practical advice they talk about
outside the box strategies and even if
you don't own a small business yourself
I think you'd be fascinated by the
content on up flip perfect for people
who like shows like Shark Tank and that
sort of thing get to the up flip YouTube
channel by going to david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is underneath the
video there friends of the david pakman
show definitely make sure to subscribe
to their channel click that Bell icon on
their page so you'll be notified
whenever they upload a new video